all right ty the bishop checkmate
check me check me i mean
how does it feel to know you are the
winner of season nine of big brother
canada
it feels unreal like i i still can't
even put it into words like i'd still it
still really hasn't sunken into me
and you know what the fact is you
mentioned it even last night
you're part of big brother history the
first black man
in the north american franchise that's a
big deal
i agree and i mean i think that was
really a big part of
why i wanted to play this game is
because i wanted to be that person
or try to be part of ensuring that
happened like this season was all about
diversity and inclusion
and i thought that would be big it's
2021 i thought it was about time
and have you talked to your family after
the win no my mom and dad
and my family they'll be ecstatic like
my mom was all about the message
and i'm like i think that message was
sent loud and clear last night so
it's crazy to me it's crazy it's such a
great feeling
and i'm so glad you played such a great
game and
you you really did play chess throughout
it i mean you changed your game when you
had to
and would you say you played the perfect
game
i mean nobody's perfect like i don't i
don't think that was your game was it
perfect was it the way you wanted to
play
yeah like what i would say is like if
there was a big brother textbook on how
to play the game i think everybody comes
in wanting to play the game i play
reality is i never touched the block i
was barely on slaw
and i mean i was with a big alliance
most of the game i didn't have to win
comps and then i won three in a row at
the end
i'm like how could you like how else
would you want to play besides doing
those moves
and let's talk about your relationship
with braden i love the fact that you
brought him all the way
so you played a little bit with him he
had a little bit of crush on you didn't
he
yeah and like the reality is like
obviously i have a lot of love for
braden like he's one of my really good
friends
and obviously like knowing that he had a
crush on me i i
it was something that of course i was
gonna play on because emotions are a
part of the game and i really wanted to
pretty much use that to ensure that he
had my back
how does it feel to be outside of the
house right now i mean you were there
the longest
um it still feels a little bit weird
like seeing trees and cars and
other people besides the people i see
every day is is
different and something i'm gonna have
to do you know and it's interesting too
because you went into the game during
the current climate
and you guys showed the world that
normalcy almost you know the fact that
you came to see
new people you guys are hugging and
living life and you know i had great
moments
and and partying as well how was that
feeling for you to be
able to just be normal again in that
house
it felt like what i think i would want
the world to look like
post covenant like it was just like it
felt like cove would ended for us for a
bit
because we were able to have that that
normalcy like
it felt really good to be around people
again to hug to kiss
to laugh like it just felt like it
reminded me how
important human interaction is it really
did and you know this year was the most
diverse cast
ever in big brother franchise and we got
to learn a little bit of history from
all of you
for you what does that represent for you
to be in that house with such
incredible people i mean
i just think for me it's special in that
sense like it's
to be a part of the most diverse and
inclusive cast
ever it's just it means it means the
world to me
like i just i i don't even know how to
put it into words like the big
personalities we had
and just the message that says the
canadians that we hear you and we see
you in this cast represented canadians
better than ever in my opinion
and when you hear the word keeper what
does that mean to you
i love kiefer keeper's probably my
favorite
he kept it real he had my back kinda
and i'm i'm not here without kiefer and
that's just yeah
so i have something what about beth i
mean there was some showmance going on
there was this triangle we were confused
what's going on
but at the end i mean the sauce all of
it
what what was going on what was going on
there
where do i even start like i don't know
beth is probably one of my favorite
house guests too like one of my favorite
characters of the season
going into it i mean i think we had a
little bit of a crush on each other but
a showmance was really not in the cards
for me
and i knew that i just knew it would put
a huge target on my back and i thought
her and jed were better matched for each
other anyways
so we had a little bit of a love
triangle situation in the start
and we just capitalized that and made it
into a real alliance and just
kind of went through the game like that
and they kind of shielded me throughout
the game because of that
now ty you're walking away with a
hundred thousand dollars
i mean do you have plans for you know
what you're gonna do with it are you
going to splurge
are you going to say what's going on i'm
like in between splurge and save right
now like par
the the adult in me is like let's invest
and maybe get some real estate
and splurging me is like let me go let
me go to the mall tomorrow
so i'm i'm really in between i'll
probably do a mix of the two
yeah i'm just excited what did you learn
about yourself being in this house i
mean you're tested emotionally
physically spiritually what what what
are you coming out of it that now
you feel is is part of you um there's a
few things like i think
how you spend your time is really
important learning that in the house we
we spent a lot of time together and you
get to think about
your family and the people who really
mean a lot to you and it reminded me how
important those people are and how
important it is to spend time with those
people
also just being able to have tough and
real honest conversations i think i
built a lot of skills having those tough
conversations
and i think that's something in the real
world that i want to be able to do
better
is have real honest tough conversations
with people and just not avoid the
confrontation
what does big brother canada mean to you
it means i don't know like when i hear
big brother canada i think
hardest thing i've ever done in my life
don't know if i'd ever do it again
but i'll it was one of the best
experiences of my life and i wouldn't
change it for the world
you were amazing congratulations on the
win
and it's so wonderful to chat with you
and uh
good luck getting out there in the world
again and uh thank you so much for
chatting with us really appreciate it
thank you san diego
you